I will talk about this topic fighting
against chaotic college separate volume
with embark so my name is Heidi for AHA
she working for this company called
George that either we actually we have a
booth and a down stair so please come to
check this company my talk today is
about this thing not the thing you think
this is an open-source project I started
so please let me explain myself so I'm a
one of the cofounders three come
foreigners of this company originator so
we are located in monkey views of South
Bay area and I'm also taka I started
this several open source products why is
called currently this is streaming based
data collection system so you can
collect from files or external services
and transfer them across servers and
then algorithm into a single page so
that you can data put data from that
single place and embodies for our
embodies for a batch oriented data
collection system so this is the today's
topic and I also started on web project
called message pack I think this is the
most successful successful project I
started a great thank you very much
so yeah this is a data serialization
format like Jason but it's this is
binary based so it's faster and more
compact I think you have noticed that
pandas supports message back as a file
format to export data although they do
so this is the topic so fighting against
CSV files using inbox so C 3 is known as
comma separated values however in
reality it's not always comma separated
after that in recent years this is
considered as characters separated
values but anyways that is chaotic how
is separated values so there are many
Pro
so first of all what is in bulk so in
bulk is an open-source data collector
that lost data from a into V and it can
be can be anything
using planets so we can support this we
files as a proto that this product also
supports other storages like SMTP FTP
rf3 or databases like my secure Bhaskar
scale or even more signal differences
and B also can be a plugin like where
this Cassandra Hadoop that is all plugin
fiving based this tool helps you to move
data across those two storages that was
very painful before here's a reason so
i'm example is that you win you need to
load 10 gigabytes of CSV file into
positive sphere ok first I think you
will write a script to load the data
into process here but probably twelve
what the reason is that the system
includes milliliter including timestamp
to load process care total data in the
Box obscure the time some format needs
to be like this this moment however the
data format could be like this is so
style forward if you prepare the system
files from my CTO usually null values
are like this point this is saying with
a hive if you load data from 50 file no
it's like this representation but it
doesn't work with postal scale so do
more normalization and that filtering to
fix the error ok great second attempt
fails because at the later part you
found another broken record which says
IMF is but it needs to be infinity to
note that to positive
so fixed we try extra traffic's we try
repeat will be working too that is
painful and you mean we are is that
somehow that data is loaded voice ah
that's a product you need to try from
the beginning again okay but script work
today
good so let's say you register the
script into clock so that you just think
the file into posture posture every day
but this will cause another program like
this one day the CSV file generated
generated by application contained an
invalid unicode byte sequence that can
wander mirrors so then that strips
silently files and then unless you fix
it the data on postal scale will not be
updated but that is very painful for
them next problem is to load a lot of a
big size of data let's say you have 10
gigabytes files 720 files
most of scripts are slow because we
don't want to send time to optimize that
speed but if we take one hour to load
one point loading 720 fires will take
one month
it never ends actually it might be
literally never end because during data
transfer that can cause metro Clara
where the database could be overloaded
other case the data loading will I fail
if you would try from the beginning
Gagner that ever might again happen so
to reduce the risk of that error or
probability of the error you need to be
try from the top that is called region
but implement that can never happen
resuming advance of time is hard we
don't want to spell such time to the
right description and this example used
CSV as the importa file format let's say
that is on the free
but there are many other formats in the
world XML JSON and open cases
application will use custom documents
and files might be on Hadoop they use
different file formats like RT files or
a cheap-ass many parts are invented
recently and there are many kinds of
strange strangest as well FTP SFTP and
of course there are many outputs as well
in this case we use possible scales an
example but elastic storage when a query
MongoDB or even Salesforce can be a
champion out of it
so to support those different things we
needed to write scripts each other but
it's been work so the problem is the
problems are so forcing files correctly
is difficult it needs to include very
escaping volatile call working hunt
encoding hungry and no hundred that is
default and error handling becomes very
complicated finding an error could be
easy but we cover you from the error is
default an optimizing performance takes
time and once ever happens the basic
approach is to retry from that but we
don't want to load data twice that a
person is to be idempotent so that the
data is loaded once or no data is loaded
then you can retry
but that kind idempotent transactional
control is foreign to employment and
their meaning with file formats many
kinds of storages in the world how to
save my time that is the province and we
are the company to elevator at those
problems so true leader is a cloud-based
data management service so you send data
to us and we process the data using
sequel and we push the results back to
you
then with this idea you can offload the
big data processing part into our side
you can do a sequel processing joining
across multiple data sources
you don't supply a machine learning so
that is good however there's a problem
so if a customer like you want to try to
you later you need to load someday
that's why that's a part of evaluation
process of course but to do that we
needed to write scripts every time and
that was taking a lot of time ok then
you find that surgery is very useful you
want to migrate existing later plus that
is huge then it also takes a long time
because that ever hand-wringing quality
required for that size later is much
higher than the one-time script infinity
which is another purposes project I
started is for streaming data collection
so data comes in and lost that
immediately 12 but that is one problem
and bulk beta loading such as dumping
everything to somewhere is under problem
they have they focus on very different
forwards so that's the reasons behind
embolic so I created this tool in bak
and bog is an open source
planning based power data loader that
makes that data loading problems much
easier and faster the important point is
here that is plugins based
so many kinds of storages and five four
months are also many kind of file
formats and habits are here if we write
scripts for each combinations we will
need m-by-n scripts that's too much but
with planning architecture if we add one
datasource plan here it media tree
supports all adverts we will not need in
buying scripts
instead what we need is an int planet
and an outer planet so it reduces the
complexity of data processing a lot the
number of squares we need is impressive
that's much smaller than Martin but then
M by M and to write those plans we need
a framework so that those plugin can
cooperate each other but that's the
purpose of invoke invoke is a reliable
framework to run those plugins and
invoke texture parallel processing
distribute the processing and
transaction control chain so let's see a
demo that should be interesting here is
a CSV file stored on my machine and
pulls the one sees lead on TV there's
one two three four five five counts ID
account time for estimate for example I
want to load this data to process scale
okay and he has posted scale its own
table first
but so there are no tables first what I
do is to write this simple confirmation
file the file is only stuff and output
is this database we want to insert the
data into process here then what I do is
just sing the file format
let them bugged yes that 5 4 1 so
valleys map
so in bulk read small amount of data
from this file and just how it is
formatted so first apparently the file
format is visit its compressed and
character encoding is utf-8 and the
limiter is come no color and the
reporting is bad and no a bad guest
performance it also just sees the
columns like this time field has time
some value and a format like this this
right yes it is correct this is actually
time formatted and here depending on I
use case though this can be integer or a
string constant so many in many cases
the timestamps are returned in this
format it's difficult for evil for human
to just that that is timestamp but we
should know that as time stopped because
it is actually times like so in bulk
also Jes is that formats like this and
right
it loaded the data the pasta scale
select from Evita yes the data is loaded
okay so this is straightforward 15 fire
I would say the real CC file is not like
this for example
created by asada 2013 let's say this
fine like this
and no might be like this it might not
exist and that could be escaped like
this format okay okay so then it might
not be comma separated like this pipe
separated that is possible right this is
a real twisted one this is the real
world embark also can just the 5 volt so
here for the limiter is pipe and no
string game like back :
it also detected the comments okay the
first 5 lines are prone treatments if
that are wrong we can fix but if that is
okay UK media to run this configuration
what a good that it is loaded here that
it is yeah okay so here's another
example you have this my postal scale
data and you want to put the data into
my secret in this case you is another
travel my secret problem the config is
I think so now I use postal scale as the
implant and my figures that plugin and
here is my signal show tables
yeah no tables then invokes rung copy
cable
okay this loaded the data
um it is the application it is a tool as
well as a library so you can run on come
on line who are load from an application
you can load within an application it so
you can embed okay so that was the demo
so this is their internal architecture
so there are implements and output
plugins there are also filter programs
so that you can convert the structure
over the data or remove unnecessary rows
and there are another plugin - just the
four months you can write for example
JSON format just boiling oh I like XML
form of display then it makes it much
easier to configure involved directly
with a am in planning there are three
kinds of internal are structure as well
why is filing that - decoder whines
parser so finally input can be strangest
like local fire I was on a three Google
Cloud Google Sites which the code can be
compiled decompression or the encryption
the processor can be CSV XML JSON that
can file forms in this case output can
be for example Oscar scale also a 3ds it
can have the same approach as well for
example CSV format there this encoder
save it to local file so that is the
structure of the image is changing
and there are many pockets release um so
as input those databases of course plus
some other external services such as
Salesforce JIRA Mixpanel
or dynamic so you can load data from
those just using plugins without writing
any code so here's the list of plugins
receipt project is so this is the
plugins list in the world and they are
open source projects so though I wrote
those projects but the other like those
written by the community open source
community Salesforce Mixpanel JIRA
HTTP reacts yes this is SSH rockhole
MongoDB so if you imagine something as a
data input that is probably already
there
there are over hundreds of plans also
has out Ravens bigquery in my cigarette
shift particle ABC so those are the
plugins filter plugins are also
interesting so this column filter
planning removes unnecessary cons for
example the data in could include
certain sensitive information like
password
you don't want to copy it then you can
remove the column using this filter body
without writing code just computation
and let's say this is a text processing
program so that you can normalize the
charts are encodings okay
many filter bodies
power supply beans mine first implements
this excellent so you can load data from
Excel files using a ball
okay
and the x-men the other filters the
filters can work between inputs and
others yep
so what so one use case is to convert a
user even come into browser main oil and
those first informations so that you can
use it at the later scripts very easily
of course another use case is that
converting an IP address into geo
locations if you have access logs like
this Christian query parameters and bog
filter plan in general also parse it
before using it in application and those
plugins are written by the community so
I won't post a scale filter plumbing but
those filter comm funny is written by
another person which is in the community
and embark of the starch is written by
my colleague so people do some work to
write plugins then they released it did
have then we can take advantage of it we
don't have to do the same thing twice
because we can package those effort into
planning
and an interesting thing that execution
engine is also traveling based so tasks
like parser decoder inputs or outputs
they were wrong and body but this layer
this execution layer is also cloud-based
the default provision called thread
local thread planning so that those
tests run on threads
this is under plugin called invoke
executor Map Reduce using this planning
you can distribute those tabs on how to
classes so that you can process huge
amount of data using multiple machines
but this is very helpful to load huge
amount of data on a3 into those services
like the Korean ship the tree later
winning originator in our system we
embed Bach as a part of our source we
load and Bob as a library in application
so our customers call REST API and this
REST API includes the information via
the data source in Yama for money and we
run embark on our environment on how to
class and load the data into a platform
using my talents
maybe this is also interesting but let's
go this first so first I will embark on
in 2015 that was the first person and I
had this many features later so one
interesting feature is region so embark
execution is divided into tasks and if
one task fails the data loading will
fail but if you we try everything from
the beginning it takes so long time so
instead of a trying from the beginning
embark has resumed from the middle or
the failure so you not have to try
everything on a failure
another thing is incremental loading and
all can't remember what happened before
and the next execution can start from
that stage here's an undemocratic
so here's the configuration file and I
run this configuration then this we
world data again but if I do this
argument does feel live the PMO it
stores what happened now
and we not copy the coffee
okay what happened now and what should
do next in this case the last puff was
this one for example in this directory
an application opens new files every day
let's emulate the situation CP v will
unconsciously - - there are two files
what we want to do is just loading one
file not the bottom both of them
important take advantage of this state
file now it skips the first part below
that is load before then loads only the
last one and updates the state's yep
they're true then if at the next
execution its tips those two files and
load only new file so that the
incremental loading
okay and that this release I added a
temperate engine feature so that you can
invent some variables into the
configuration file like password hotline
that campaign can be read from
environment variables tolling bundle is
all the important thing when you deploy
the things on production environment so
one challenge to have a plumbing
architecture that the versions of Belize
deployments variable people release new
clients every day and that might be
incompatible with with the current
behavior so in production you want to
fix the versions of those plugins in
this case in Python for example we use
file called requirements of text then
that file includes the versions of the
libraries same thing in volcanoes this
feature called in bulk bundle to fix
those versions on production environment
Oh current version okay so this one this
is a bit all slice sorry
adding JSON come fight is done so invoke
now it can support JSON column types
this is very useful when you have
steamos data inputs such as JSON files
of course or MongoDB though they don't
have schema they have Timmons database
at that case having fixed schema is not
good because the schema can change every
time so having Jason tab helps it helps
it okay so those are yeah so there we
are future paths so one change I found
after releasing a book is that ever
handling is a lot of configuration so
here's an example
in this fire so I first just the format
of this like this moment but the data
might include some broken data like this
is broken but like this format in this
case the default behavior of embark is
to skip the data the reason that in most
cases you want to process the other
records first then think about small
amount of work on records later but it's
not always true especially in some
production environment you don't want to
produce wrong results unless you are
sure that everything is loaded that is
because people need to have trust from
the results otherwise if if the data is
sometimes broken sometimes correct that
is hard to trust the results so
depending on the use case is going to
handle the errors differently so that is
one thing I am going to add to this
project of course I'm having more guests
is another fifth thing and having
multiple jobs is also one thing so if we
have a lot of tables in a database
currently one bulk data loading can have
the one single table in terms of it
under state storage but if you have
hundreds of tables on database you need
to run hundreds of involvement that is
all right so idea here is to run
multiple things using a single file okay
so here's another topic related to that
so the one data loading process consists
of multiple processes first loading data
from my Sybil running from data from
Fossett scale loading data from
Salesforce join that into a single be
accept that is one process the next
thing is processing the data actually
like applying machine learning or
applying swifts that is other process at
the end you want to validate that is
correct
then dump everything into a production
straight so the whole process consists
of multiple space steps by design so
here's another open source project we
are working on to automate the back row
so dig that this is this this tool is
called given The Dig Dug runs multiple
paths with dependence with each other in
order who are in peril if possible this
can automate a any kind of manual work
you are doing so you can think that is a
sort of which make file with a
scheduling feature in building
so here's one example of data aligned
with classifying is that task so first
loads data using in bulk downloading
data from a tree to local file then use
another operator here to run a sequel on
postal scale and download the results in
the log file then run Python scripts to
process the data apply more work using
Python scripts and then dump the results
in the postal scale using a more
comparative so this is how your workflow
is configured using Diggler you can also
run this sort of loop also and also
power execution when you use a Python
script like this we can pass you want to
pass some parameters say this sets a
variable interval and the next test uses
it Bigler we can map those parameters
into the arguments of other methods in
this case there are two parameters set
by this planet sample 10/100/1000
features at the ID name city they will
be set here and in this case these
tracking groups is method for those
parameters and this Python script can
set some variables like this using this
debug module so that the next test like
this can use it
here's also a demo okay
this is a bit funny [ __ ] not practical
demo but you don't understand how after
it works so steps here is to set the
current value current time variable here
and set the end of time of this the talk
is until 2:30 2:30 all right three okay
then said the end time to this body up
and using those two parameters current
time and end time calculate how many
minutes I have then set it to another
variable if that is smaller than 10
minutes run a shell script to execute
this command say seize the command to
say something and I also have some loop
here okay if I write here okay
I have only find me so I need to hurry
up so the last thing you saw is a group
so in this case the tunnel added here
this term is here it was apt go and okay
so there were three groups and feeling
was exclamation in question so for each
combination this group happened so
that's why you heard hurry for six times
okay that was the demo so this is under
very active development and it'll find
its own website by googling this digger
so pre-sorted thank you very much
and I'd like to take some questions yes
that's a very question up there very
good question
so embark itself is a schema for system
so embark has type system invoke support
integers string timestamp boolean JSON
and Inc planet needs to convert all
those types into this intermediate part
multiple planets must support those
types then with this this way even
though imp doesn't know about anything
about output important coordinate to
convert all types if output doesn't
supports such a timestamp for example
not a planet needs to think how to
convert I'm stuck this is a work by the
private developer why there is the
convert into string winder is compared
to expand
you know christen
yes
problems can be within java or will be
forced on the current support inside
process generally generally yes
generally because executors itself is
also alive so that default pani local
integrated planning those data as those
those pattern into memory but MapReduce
executor this should be the packages in
two different machines yes as a planning
management system in vogue has its own
packaging system so there's a planning
release site so release on that and then
back in other words our planning is to
include everything in the package
there's one reason to the why I did that
architecture so well in this case in
Bacchus Java at the core and if we load
balanced in a single process dependent
libraries will conflict the same file
might exist here and here and they have
different versions and things will be
blocking but it's not good
instead I decided to have isolated
environment each other so that they
don't conflict they can use different
versions of libraries different versions
drivers and they can run in a single
process without conflict
yes
ah that is a big so answer is not there
no UI for those degrak though that is
another project is going to have UI but
that is also under development this is
sort of out for question yet this logo
is even
margin is merging two data sources or
yes it does yes it does for example I
think you mean databases I possibly
scale my signal so this is a judgement
of the planet
yes so PostgreSQL plumbing supports in
short truncate dumping sort which means
we please replace as well and marsh much
Margie's record using a unique truncate
insert and replace looks similar but
actually different because twenty ring
sort keeps the table and inserting
records so it keeps the steel replace is
more optimized it creates a new table at
the at the end it replaces the table
this is more optimal but cannot keep
indexes or doeskin if you have some
strategies in your mind with say the
name then I can find the names I think
you bro
a patch error is not supported
unfortunately I know the product I'm
coming out with that project invokes
support message but instead though
because like we do thank you very much